do you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of aegon's enemies
a story we agree to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
in this video i want to mostly talk
about what happened on the night aegon
the conqueror brought fire and blood to
the enormous castle known as harrenhal
as you all know the upcoming hbo series
house of the dragon will
be based on george r martin's book fire
and blood
in my last video i said i wanted to
start making videos on the chapters from
fire and blood because there is a good
chance we could learn more about this
information
in the new series house of the dragon as
i was reading the first chapter in fire
and blood i decided i would make this
video based on some of the information
given
in that first chapter which covers
aegon's conquest
this is one of the many scenes i would
love to see brought to life on the
television screen
now even if you haven't read any of the
books i am sure most of you will
remember harrenhal from game of thrones
all of you should remember the location
because this is where jaime revealed
what happened during the night he
executed the mad king
this is where brienne fought the bear
and this is also where arya shared many
scenes with tywin lannister
and jack nagar i think this is one of
the most fascinating castles in all of
the seven kingdoms
however if you have only seen game of
thrones then you might not know that
much about why this castle now looks
like a graveyard
the show did give us a basic description
about what happened here
but in this video i want to go over some
of the more interesting details about
the castle
in that historical event
greatest fortress ever built tallest
towers the strongest walls
the great hall had 35 paths
35 can you imagine the man who is
responsible for commanding the
construction of the largest castle in
westeros
which set right on the northern shore of
the god's eye was known as harren horror
also known as heron the black he was the
last of the kings of the isles
and the rivers to rule over the iron
islands and the riverlands
one thing i want to do is give you a
sense of just how massive harrenhal was
because it's just absolutely insane
it's said that harrenhal is the biggest
castle in westeros
but what exactly does that mean well
it's also said that harrenhal's chambers
were built on a scale that would be more
suitable for giants than your average
man
harrenhal actually has the largest
chamber in westeros
larger than the iron throne room and the
red key the castle has these five
massive towers that makes it look as if
the castle has
fingers reaching for the sky harren hall
actually covers three times the amount
of land winterfell does
and where winterfell only has three
acres for its godswood
harrenhal has 20 acres of land for its
godswood
now one of the details that really
struck a nerve with me is how heron the
black ordered men to cut down
three thousand-year-old werewood so he
can use them as rafters
and beams in his castle this castle
actually has
kitchens that are roughly the same size
as winterfell's great hall
and it also has stables that can house a
thousand horses
many also believe that this castle could
garrison
1 million men basically everything about
this castle
is off the charts by the time harrenhal
was finished
heron the black was an old man who now
had gray hair
because the construction of this castle
lasted for nearly
40 years now although herron's house had
full control over these lands for three
generations
the men of this region had no love for
their ironborn leaders
heron the black had sent thousands of
men to an early grave
during the construction of his great
castle harrenhal
you see king heron had enslaved the
riverlands to raise the mightiest
fortress westeros had ever seen
now in order to build something that big
there has to be a lot
and i mean a lot of resources this
is one of the many reasons why he
started to lose support by the time
aegon's conquest began
when you consider the amount of lives
that were lost and the amount of
resources in that area that were used up
during the construction of heron hall
you can start to see why the riverlands
he once ruled over
were now beginning to rise up against
him now what's really interesting is
on the same exact day the new castle was
finally finished
aegon targaryen landed at the mouth of
the blackwater rush
to start his conquest to westeros herron
the black
in his newly built castle was about to
face their greatest test
so as aegon and his sisters were gearing
up for an attack on harrenhal
harren the black summoned lord edmund
tawley of riverrun
but as i said before since the
riverlands were beginning to rise up
against hair in the black
instead of defending harrenhal lord
edmund talley declared for house
targaryen instead
he raised a dragon banner over his
castle then rode
forth with his knights and archers to
join aegon the dragon
that was a big moment for everyone else
in the riverlands because that gave them
another reason to abandon hair and the
black
and join forces with aegon targaryen
that's exactly what happened
the blackwoods the malistars the vances
the freys the brackens and many others
descended on harrenhal
rather than defend it as soon as king
heron the black realized he was
outnumbered
he took refuge in what he thought was
the greatest fortress in all the lands
heron the black laughed as he locked his
gates and settled down with his
remaining sons
and supporters to withstand a siege he
was confident that aegon and his men
were no match for the castle
he did have an unlimited supply of water
massive vaults stalked with food
and giant walls of stone that were
higher than any ladder
and too thick to be broken by any
battering ram or shattered by any
trebuchet
he was ready for this day or so he
thought
you see harrenhal may have been able to
withstand an assault from all the armies
in westeros combined
but this great fortress was no match for
dragon fire
right after heron locked himself in a
castle aegon sent his maester to the
gates under a peace banner so they could
negotiate
hair in the black went out to meet him
looking all old and gray
yet still fierce in his black armor both
of the kings had their maester in
attendance
so the words that they exchanged are
still remembered
yield now aegon began and you may remain
as lord of the iron islands
yield now and your sons will live to
rule after you
i have 8 000 men outside your walls
what is outside my walls is no concern
to me said hair in the black
my walls are strong and thick aegon
responded by saying
but not so high to keep out dragons
dragons fly
i built them in stone said hair in the
black stone does not burn
aegon ends the conversation by saying
when the sun sets
your line shall end it is said that
heron sped at that
and then walked back to his castle as
soon as he was inside
he sent all of his men outside to defend
the castle
he offered lands and gold to any man who
could bring down the dragon
he also said if i had a daughter you
could have her as well
now that edmund tully had joined forces
with aegon
harren the black then said instead i
will give the man who brings down the
dragon
one of the tally's daughters or all
three of them if he likes
it makes no difference to me herron the
black was ready for war
right as the sun was about to set herron
the black's men stared out into the
darkness
holding on to their weapons knowing what
was about to happen next
after another few moments had went by
they thought that maybe aegon had
left maybe his threats were hollow but
aegon targaryen had something else in
mind
on the back of his dragon valeria on the
black dread he went up into the sky
as high as he could up and up and up
until the dragon looked as if it were no
bigger than a fly sitting upon the moon
only then did he descend well inside the
castle walls
belarion the dread was blacker than the
night sky
moving through the air like a missile as
he dove through the clouds
when he had the castle in his sights the
dragon erupted like a volcano
as his fire rained down upon them stone
walls do not burn
hair in the black said but his castle
was not made of stone alone
wood and hemp and straw and bread salted
beef and
grain were all set ablaze hair and the
black's iron men were not made of stone
either
smoking screaming and shrouded in flames
they ran across the yard and fell from
the walls to die upon the ground below
even the stone began to crack and melt
when the fire became hot enough
the riverlords outside the castle wall
said later that the five great towers of
harrenhal glowed red against the night
like five great candles melting up in
the sky
heron the black and his remaining sons
died in the fire that engulfed his
enormous castle that night
his entire house died with him on the
very next day
as they were standing outside the
smoking ruins of harrenhal
king aegon targaryen accepted fealthy
from edmund talley
lord of riverrun and named him the lord
paramount of the trident
when the ashes had cooled enough to
allow the men to enter the castle safely
the swords of the fallen many shattered
or melted steel by dragon fire
were gathered up and sent back to the
aegon fort and wagons
later to become some of the swords that
would make up the iron throne
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
[Music]
you